hey guys this novel coronavirus pandemic
has truly affected all of us across the
globe but one of the hardest hit
communities has been healthcare
frontline workers this means doctors
nurses CMAs respiratory therapists
technicians custodial staff and so many
more today I'd like to take a focus and
celebrate doctors in memory of those
who've laid down their lives in the
battle against kovat 19 I sat down and I
interviewed over a hundred physicians to
get their take their experiences and
learn their perspectives about the
coronavirus know that all the revenue
generated from this video adsense
donations and even merch sales link down
below are all going to the CDC
foundation to help continue this battle
against kovat 19 the first question I
asked these doctors what do you think is
not getting enough attention I wish
there was more credit and awareness
being given to other members of the
health care teams aside from just the
doctors and the nurses Tech's
transporters housekeeping kitchen staff
valets operators x-ray a laboratory
radiology techs EMTs janitorial staff
the cafeteria workers the respiratory
therapists the nurses and everyone else
here on the front lines is towards our
ability to do our jobs the number of
doctors and healthcare professionals out
there who've gotten seriously ill even
lost their lives fighting this disease
some healthcare workers have been
disciplined for speaking up about the
lack of personal protective equipment
testing is an area we need a huge amount
of focus on an attention on in the UK we
need antibody tests we need to know who
has immunity in many communities the
small number of cases being reported is
simply a reflection of lack of testing
how coronavirus is and will affect
certain communities our homeless
community our community of people with
special needs the domestic abuse and
domestic violence that is happening
during a pandemic with victims being in
the same home as perpetrators for longer
periods of time in this quarantine we've
limited and cut the number
one can have before she delivers
visitorís family really no one is
allowed to be at the bedside when you're
infected with Kovac if you look closely
you will see that there are young people
who are otherwise well who can get
seriously ill we can't really see the
emotional toll that the outbreak has on
us the effect that this is all having on
our mental health and well-being mental
health problems don't stop just because
we have an infectious disease pandemic
I've had patients who haven't been able
to get cancer surgery who've had
significant heart problems and not been
able to get them worked up if people who
now feel sick from cancer are now
discouraged from going to hospitals
because all the attention now is on
kovat 19 then we're gonna miss some of
those patients right now we're
postponing all the non urgent cases and
when things are live days we're gonna
see everyone come back all at once
I was once supposed to date in this
point in time are we just supposed to
get to know people by Zhu min FaceTime
yeah virtual dating is a thing now for
my next question I asked what does it
mean for you to be a doctor now it means
a 30-minute decontamination routine
before I get to hug my kids every time I
come home from the hospital practicing
medicine during this pandemic means what
it always means protecting the
vulnerable this is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to boldly fulfill my oath
and desire to save lives
the Koba 19 pandemic has me in a place
where I've never felt more connected to
my profession have an opportunity to
step up and really honor my own I really
feel like it's a privilege for me to be
able to practice medicine during the
pandemic it allows me to serve my
community when my community needs me
most I'm old enough to have lived
through the early years of the AIDS
epidemic and it had a similar feeling
you know you were in the middle of
something incredibly important my mother
gave me a magnet a long time ago that
said not all heroes wear capes some of
them were SEPA scopes I'm not running
away from it I'm running toward it we're
ready we signed up for this we took an
oath it's a privilege to be part of the
solution it's an honor to care for
patients and their families and to help
navigate them through these very
challenging times
a calling and a vocation I've never
viewed it on the job this isn't a job
this is a calling I couldn't agree more
next I asked how have you been
personally affected by the corona virus
when we put a breathing tube in for a
patient which we have to do for almost
every surgery we're really exposed to
everything that's in that patient's
mouth or throat or airway it's like
looking down the barrel of a gun I'll be
moving out of our house soon and into
someplace that's closer to the hospital
and where I won't risk infecting my own
family should I move out should I play
with in the home I haven't seen my mom
or my dad or any family members in the
last few weeks some sick family members
I don't know when I'll see them next I
wasn't able to kiss my wife on our
anniversary this year because of
coronavirus a beautiful wife and I are
about to bring new life into this world
and with that comes fear worry and
anxiety
both of my daughter's work with me here
at the Cleveland Clinic I'm worried for
the family but we're gonna do this my
entire family lives and practices of
South Carolina annually and when I read
in the news that 2027 physicians as of
yesterday have contracted the virus and
many have died from it it gave me chills
I recently got sick with a lot of the
features have covered 19 without testing
I've got no way of knowing if I had it
for sure I don't know if I'll be
infected again I don't know if I'm going
to infect my patients I did get Corona I
was actually six for two weeks had
pneumonia and it was probably the worst
health experience that I've ever been
through
I developed a fever and a lot of the
coded symptoms when I ended up in the
emergency room all I could think about
was when I recover will this make me
immune so I can get back out there for
the first time ever lately I've been
having the sense of uneasiness as I
Drive into work I've personally seen a
lot of death
that you know I don't know if residency
could ever prepare you for because our
pain clinics closed out last week and
before I'll be transitioning to
telemedicine soon there's still a gap
where I'll be unemployed as a pain
management fellow and that leaves me
financially unstable so I'm still paying
rent overhead staff supplies all of the
above with basically no income I'm a
physician on Oahu and it's challenging
caring for my neighbor Island patients
on Maui and the Big Island
hydroxychloroquine has been getting a
lot of press during this pandemic and
the availability of this medication has
been a big concern for myself and for my
patients I've been forced to delay
important heartbeat and heart rhythm
procedures for several of my patients I
lost child care so my toddler keeps
barging into all of my appointments and
that's probably a HIPAA violation hey I
can relate bear walks into some of my
patient visits too next I asked how can
we help from home believe it or not not
everyone is taking social distancing
seriously the virus doesn't spread on
its own people spread the virus so you
are on the front line in this pandemic
even small indulgences like going to a
park around other people can have huge
consequences that you don't even feel in
the moment treat every outside contact
as something potentially infected no
matter how healthy or save someone or
something looks this thing does not care
what you look like how much money you
have or how wealthy you are so you have
to stay home no cheating
I know it gets really boring at home
sometimes and all you want to do is just
be with your friend just for a minute
but please for our sake stay homes stay
home that's how you fight the virus get
comfortable and stay there Netflix and
chill YouTube and thrill
please please please stay home help us
help you help me help you stay hydrated
get some sleep eat healthy don't smoke
it please do some exercise while you're
home here's my prescription for you stay
home we are not stuck at home we're safe
at home safe at home not stuck at home
and please treat everyone with kindness
everyone knows someone who is putting
their life at risk by working during
these difficult times just send them a
thank you continue sending positive
vibes and continue
reaching out to those who are in their
support system who need their help and
just be kind to each other everyone's
having a hard time physical distancing
is crucial but it should not cause
social isolation call or FaceTime your
friends your family your significant
others the virus mainly infects through
mucous membranes of the eyes nose and
mouth so even if we were clogs and we
wear masks if we touch our face we can
still get infected washing your hands
and no I'm not just talking like Oh wash
wash wash and you're done I'm talking a
full 20 seconds wash your hands wash
your hands multiple times throughout the
day really diligent hand-washing wash
your hands and as I say to my
five-year-old don't pick your nose be
wary of the browsers and the Pickers at
the grocery store you know I'm talking
about those people that are picking up
avocados and putting them right back by
being very careful of your internet
hygiene because spreading false
information can be deadly everyone has a
role to play in making sure that we
spread correct information to stop
spreading misinformation on social media
I think this is very important just
following credible media outlets don't
give in to the Asteria top thing on my
mind is remembering to stay flexible and
lean into uncertainty have those
difficult end of life discussions you
will feel at peace knowing your loved
ones wishes whether the time comes
tomorrow or a decade from now ask
neighbors to put up a red piece of paper
in their window if they need assistance
immediately a yellow piece means I need
help but not urgently and green means
things are okay and please know that
like when the scientists are saying
these things we're not saying them
because we're out to get you we're
saying them because we care about you
that's right
we're on Team you my final question what
gives you hope it gives me goosebumps
but I think about what you see around
you doctors nurses social workers
respiratory therapists environmental
services each and every one of us is
doing what we can
I have the best ICU nurses in the world
the unity the compassion and empathy
humanity exists and we're all in this
together I live in New York City and
every night at seven o'clock the entire
city breaks out in cheer and applause
for all the health care workers
[Applause]
I'm hearing from families who are having
more family meals more family meetings
they're playing board games they're
communicating they're talking people are
coming together and they are helping out
their neighbors letters like this in my
mailbox for my neighbor spreading love
across this country every patient that I
called first thing they ask is how was I
doing the outpouring of love and support
from communities all around the world
showing their support for health care
workers like me on the front lines all
of our frontline workers in hundreds of
roles inside the hospital and outside of
it working their tails off every single
day my training is all stepping up to
volunteer to help in the ICU health care
professionals everywhere are stepping up
instead of backing down the emergency
department staff now more than ever
we've put aside old turf wars and
interdepartmental bickering the fact
that the world has set aside its
differences to work on novel treatments
vaccines and drugs for this virus the
people donating and making supplies like
when we see businesses that stop their
work and start producing equipment for
health care providers even famous
fashion designers like Chanel and
Christian Siriano are making masks and
gowns the numbers are getting better
prevention does work seeing people on
their balconies applauding those on the
frontlines gives me hope and seeing
science working creating vaccines
creating treatments is what gives me
hope I'm fighting for the hope that one
day very soon we overcome this that we
get back to normal life and don't take
the small things for granted again and
you know what gives me hope the fact
that I was able to get over a hundred of
my physician colleagues to make this
video for you I usually sign off my
videos by saying stay happy and healthy
but for this one let's do something
different
stay alert not anxious
you